do you want to say hi to YouTube
Facebook and twitch I refuse okay hi
everybody good to see you we got YouTube
YouTube Facebook we got twitch
we got Facebook in that house no one has
said that in 20 years Colton and I
versus these two guys look at you you're
paler than I am let your hair mouth
Animus prime says Conan is completely
lost here you are correct I will do I'm
21 you were playing this game in utero I
want to be a girl with red hair combats
there that's what I was for most of my
childhood there we go she has an axe
there's your girl my girl here she goes
yes she's spinning the ball boy she died
terrible got it you got it you got it
you won
did I just win yeah what is it I won
having never played the game before I
will now be better than any of them good
look at this you guys actually have a
shirt for me and I'll look at that I've
got my name on it
oh good yeah oh but random will say
you're winning oh okay what happened
victory who won did I win did you win no
why would you say I want if I didn't win
you huh let's give it up for complaint
[Applause]